foreign
[Music]
environments like Cloud functions are
powerful you get to focus on your code
but the cherry on top is being able to
connect them to other services in a
virtual private cloud or VPC in this
video you will learn how to connect your
serverless environments to resources in
a VPC with a private IP assigned
now you might think that setting this up
will add more to your plate but there's
a magic tool that will do this
connection for you serverless VPC access
it allows you to connect and send
requests from any serverless
environments such as Cloud run app
engine standard or Cloud functions to
your VPC network using an internal
Network it uses a resource name
serverless VPC access connector that
handles the traffic between a serverless
environment and PPC Network
serverless VPC exercise connector is
used to send requests from serverless
environments to your VPC Network without
using the public internet while using
the connector ensure the following it
has to be attached to a specific VPC
Network and region the connector must be
in the same region as your serverless
services and your serverless services
are configured to use the same connector
for outbound Network traffic today I'll
show you the different scenarios in
which resources hosted in a VPC or
outside a VPC can be connected from
serverless environments like Cloud
functions we will use cloud SQL as a
resource in all the scenarios let's
start with the first scenario Cloud
functions is deployed in the same region
as Cloud SQL and we will connect these
two using a public IP over the internet
now let's look at the second scenario
the cloud SQL instance is moved to a VPC
Network and its success is restricted
through private IP only
this is where we will make use of
serverless VPC access connector to
connect and Route traffic from cloud
functions to Cloud SQL instance
finally in the third scenario the cloud
SQL instance will be hosted in a
different region than the serverless VPC
access connector
for this you must use a different
network and assign it an IP range of
10.8.0.0
28 to the connector this ensures that
the source IP address for any request
sent from the connector will be from
this IP range
before we get started ensure the
following prerequisites are met the
organization policy name resource
location constraint allows you to deploy
the Google Cloud functions in the
specific region and the apis listed here
are enabled to understand how this works
let's dive into a demo as a prerequisite
you will need to have a postgres
instance created with a database defined
and some sample data refer to the quick
start link provided in the description
to learn how to do this
here we already have created an instance
name my postgres which contains a
database name guestbook with a table
named entries
next go to Cloud functions page here we
have deployed a cloud functions named
connect postgres that connects to a
postgres DP instance name my postgres
and runs a search query
please note we will be using this Cloud
functions in all the three scenarios in
our demo
in the first scenario the cloud SQL
instance is accessible over public IP
and is in the same region U.S Central 1
as Cloud functions
that's the function yay it is successful
now let's move the cloud SQL instance to
a VPC network with a private IP and
allocate an IP range for this
edit the instance select private IP
under the connection section
choose the network of your preference in
this example we will use the default
Network
allocate an IP range
and create a connection
test the same Cloud functions oops it's
failing with an exception
check the logs to see if you have any
further details we see
Cloud SQL connection field error
why does this error occur
this error occurs because we do not have
a serverless VPC access connector in the
same network as the cloud SQL instance
to address this issue go to VPC Network
and select serverless VPC access
create a serverless VPC access connector
in the default network with IP range
10.8.0.0 28
let's name it test connector
ensure the connector is in the same
region as the cloud functions U.S
Central One in our case
Let's test the function again
it's successful and we are getting the
output of the select query as expected
finally let's try to connect the cloud
SQL instance hosted in a different
region than the connector
create a cloud SQL instance in Us East
one while our existing connector is in
US Central One
we have created a cloud SQL instance
name my postgres2
ensure the cloud function and SQL
instance are using the same network
let's quickly update the functions
variable with the new instance details
and test it wow congratulations it is
successful
for more information on connecting
directly to resources on your virtual
private Cloud network from serverless
environments check out this
documentation thanks for watching
foreign
[Music]